but in saying that I mean I did years
later start a YouTube channel and
similarly my dad told me to not waste my
time doing that one either but because
that incident that I had with the
wrestling with taking his advice there
and then bothered me so much to that day
I was able to push that to the side and
actually focus on this YouTube gig that
I was kind of like you know making
myself work on and needless to say I
learned my lesson but to this day part
of me still wonders what my life might
have looked like had I not been too
scared to follow through with what was
at the time my biggest dream
um it might not have worked out it might
have who knows I don't but yeah that's
my story about wrestling about how I
almost but didn't become a wrestler